y alejandro quiere saber si la mediana
de la muestra es un estimador in sesgado
de la mediana de la población coloco
pelotas de tenis de mesa numeradas del 0
al 32 en un contenedor y las mezclo nota
que la mediana de la población es 16
alejandro tomo una muestra aleatoria de
5 pelotas y calculó la mediana de la
muestra reemplazó las pelotas y repitió
el proceso para un total de 50
ejecuciones su resultado se resume en la
siguiente gráfica de puntos cada punto
representa la mediana de una muestra de
cinco pelotas esta es la distribución
muestral de la mediana de la muestra
aquí tenemos una población de pelotas si
conocemos el parámetro sabemos que la
mediana de la población es 16 esto es la
población y se toman varias muestras de
5 pelotas como lo estoy dibujando aquí y
se calcula la mediana de cada muestra
repite esto varias veces hasta completar
las 50 ejecuciones en esta gráfica hay
50 puntos cada punto corresponde a la
mediana de una de las muestras que
alejandro tomó por ejemplo en este caso
el encontró 4 muestras cuya mediana fue
igual a 20
aquí tuvo dos muestras cuya mediana fue
19 sólo una de las muestras tuvo una
mediana de 4 nos preguntan con base en
los resultados es la mediana de la
muestra un estimador sesgado o in
sesgado de la mediana de la población
causa en el vídeo y traten de responder
esta pregunta para que un estimador in
sesgado que es lo que siempre queremos
tener un estimador integrado la
distribución muestral para esta
estadística debe estar distribuida de
manera balanceada alrededor del
parámetro verdadero de la población en
el enunciado nos dicen que la mediana de
la población es 16 esto es lo que
queremos estimar aquí está la mediana de
la población si vemos la distribución
muestral vemos que está más o menos
balanceada a la derecha ya la izquierda
del valor verdadero de este parámetro
por lo que parece que es sin sesgada ya
que la distribución muestral está
balanceada a la derecha y a la izquierda
del valor verdadero de la mediana de la
población si por ejemplo la distribución
se viera algo así o si se viera algo así
entonces estaría sesgada si lo hiciera
así sin
de esta distribución muestral subestima
constantemente el parámetro verdadero y
si se viera así entonces significa que
la distribución está sobreestimando
constantemente el parámetro es verdadero
veamos otro ejemplo las siguientes
gráficas de puntos muestran una
aproximación de la distribución de
muestreo para tres estimadores
diferentes del mismo parámetro de la
población si el valor verdadero del
parámetro de la población es 5 que
gráfica de puntos muestra el estimador
con bajo sesgo y poca variabilidad pausa
en el vídeo y tratan de responder esta
pregunta el parámetro de la población
que queremos estimar es 5 vamos a
mostrarlo en cada una de estas
aproximaciones de distribuciones
muestrales vamos a completar nuestras
escalas 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 y aquí también 1
2 3 4 5 6 y 7 ahora sí señalamos dónde
está el parámetro de la población en
cada gráfica cuál de estos estadísticos
parecen ser sesgados pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar
la gráfica con sesgo una que se nota que
tiene sesgo es la del estadístico sep al
ver la distribución muestral vemos que
está consistentemente por debajo del
parámetro verdadero lo está subestimando
constantemente así que ésta tiene sesgo
en cambio a los estadísticos a ive
parecen no tener riesgo ya que lucen más
o menos balanceados alrededor del
parámetro verdadero recuerden que estas
son aproximaciones a la distribución
muestral si queremos acercarnos cada vez
más a la distribución muestral verdadera
debemos seguir tomando muestras calcular
sus estadísticas y agregarlas a la
gráfica el estadístico a luz es
razonablemente balanceado aunque no está
perfectamente balanceado lo mismo sucede
con el estadístico ve se ve
razonablemente balanceado a la derecha y
a la izquierda en el enunciado no sólo
nos preguntan por el estimador que tiene
menos sesgo sino también por el
estimador con poca variabilidad podemos
decir que tanto el estadístico ad como
el estadístico b tienen poco sesgo pero
con respecto a la
o qué tan dispersa está la gráfica del
parámetro parece que el estadístico a
está menos disperso que el estadístico
ver pues el estadístico bet tiene
valores que están muy alejados del
parámetro verdadero en cambio los puntos
del estadístico a están a la mitad de la
distancia del parámetro verdadero el
estadístico que tiene poco sesgo y poca
variabilidad es el estadístico a nos
vemos en otro vídeo